Cái là giọt mại sai số giãn tiếp kênh hợp với chup tiếp,
học sinh lắm với mà không làm cái gì này được mơ đặt tảm nhiệm đi.
Sai, câu này thì người ta cho thông số của quán gường,
và thông số thời gian có sai số lối.
Đó là ta cho một cái câu tụi lì này,
câu tụi này thì là sao số giãn tiếp,
đúng không?
Đúng không?
Chí man yêu,
Chí doc đây bị phương,
đây là hồi bụng không bố nhé.
Cái mình là cái thằng thằng ở đâu rồi.
Ló là nó thằng chup buy nhé.
Bởi mà hay là, không bố nhé.
Chíng phải bởi tạm tạm.
Cô bởi tạm.
Đúng không?
Để mình mới đồ mình biết không có sai số tỷ đủ.
Sai số tỷ đối với công tương như này thì sao tỷ đối với mà nhé.
Mình cũng muốn tầy mình phương lời.
Tầy sai số tỷ đối của gờ.
Sẽ bằng sai số tỷ đối của F,
cậm vui hai lần.
Sa số tỷ đối của tầy.
Đúng không?
Nhìn nhẹn vụ của chúng ta muốn vết lại sai số tỷ mình thêm nữa.
Tỷ đối với chị là tỷ mình thêm để em.
Nên tạc gờ này.
Sẽ nó bọng mà nhiều đúng không?
Tầy mình là mình nhìn nhá mình biết là này.
Sa số tỷ đối của gờ nó sau khiến tầy chứa chung mình.
Sau khiến tạc,
cho Ectrong mình.
Cậu hai lần để nó tìm.
Chờ tầy chung mình nhẹn.
Tìm mình là ai một tình gờ nó không?
Tế chính nhìn.
Tìm thầy lý này là sao?
Lúng sao?
Nãy mình nhìn thầy lý này sau.
Nào, anh thấy số vật nhé.
Tạy Ectrong mình là bằng một.
Đúng không?
Chờ cho Ectrong mình là bằng chi tạm.
Vô hiểu không?
Để nó tầy là không phải không?
Chờ Ectrong mình.
A chiều tầy chung mình là không phải bằng không muốn.
Và nhìn mình nhau em.
Nhìn mình gờ chung mình.
Gờ chung mình của tình gái chi ở trên này này.
Chính phẩm ở đây vậy, đó.
Anh em thì ra được thằng lên tăng hợp.
Vào.
Lên tăng hợp xong không phải 2 năm muốn.
Mày chình ra.
Để đây có các thường số tỷ vết được gờ rồi.
Bằng gờ chung mình này.
Cậm chứ lên tăng hợp.
Anh.
Thì hụi cái phía sai số ngũ gán tiêu trọc.
Anh sẽ nhìn nó cạnh phép phía sai số ngũ gán tiêu.
Đúng không?